this morning on the dish a woman who's
making Indian cooking a lot less
intimidating
Priya Krishna was born and raised in
Dallas and loved the foods her mother
prepared based on traditional Indian
recipes but with a modern American twist
after becoming a food writer for major
magazines and newspapers she decided to
share these unique creations with the
rest of us they're found in her new
cookbook Indian ish named one of the
best cookbooks of the spring by the New
York Times food and wine and it seems
almost everybody else good morning
welcome to the dish
thanks for being here can we talk about
the color beautiful
tell us what's here all right so
starting there we've got a red pepper
peanut and potato subzi really easy six
ingredient throw it together on a
weeknight dish your tomato rice with
crispy cheddar it's a fusion between a
Spanish rice a South Indian tomato rice
and to make the kids eat it my mom put a
Shiva trigger thank you mom
and we've got my uncle hey month his
fish cooked in parchment the secret
ingredient is Hema
okay months I was a chopped up piece of
a Clementine which adds texture and
flavor Wow and this is a quick pickle
with cherry tomatoes chilies and a bunch
of really like crunchy pungent spices
here we've got a eggless pineapple cake
pineapple cake is one of those really
classic desserts and Indian cooking and
a lot of people don't eat eggs so you
know it's light and fluffy and airy and
then to drink
we've got chacón G which are airline air
some tequila cheer and pepper
open this cookbook with coming to terms
with your identity mm-hmm talk about
that yeah I mean I certainly I grew up
in Dallas Texas I went to a school that
was mostly white I just wanted to fit in
I wanted to my school was mostly Jewish
I wanted to even go back
they are fantastic I can deduce you do
tell your mother that yeah oh I did and
she was very confused and so you know I
didn't want to eat ball travel for
dinner I wanted to have spaghetti I
wanted to just do what my friends did I
remember for years I made my mom pack me
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches for
lunch because I didn't want to eat ball
I just I didn't want to do anything that
made me seem different well it's like
you talk about it as being this Indian
ish upbringing explain that term it's
obviously that's even the title in the
cookbook yeah I mean it's for this
feeling of being existing in two worlds
but not really feeling like you belong
in one and kind of coming to terms with
you know that doesn't have to be a bad
thing
it's amazing that my mom makes pizza on
roti oh yeah yeah we listen to Bollywood
hits intermixed with top 40 hits that
sounds like we wear courses with jeans
it sort of infuses every part of our
identity you know this is this is what
it's this is what the Indian American
experience is I think you got your start
writing for your college paper basically
about how they could improve the food in
the dining hall
yeah yes I love kind of an
unconventional start I wanted a food
column but I went to school in Hanover
New Hampshire over there are five
dressed ront so I was like I'm gonna run
out of content yeah yeah do a restaurant
column so it became how do you hack your
dining halls how do you make
extraordinary meals out of just the
ingredients you find and it ended up
really resonating I remember one time
for Halloween someone literally dressed
up as my persona the dds tatata by doing
like a trench coat with bananas attached
to it I've made it awesome well that
this cookbook is really a collaboration
of you and your mom what was it like to
work with her honor I mean it was great
in all the ways working with your mom
was great and she's an amazing
collaborator my mom is a project manager
at heart so she was very good at keeping
us on task keeping us up beat keeping us
very organized but we had many moments
where we were bickering where she was
secretly adding you know cumin to the
pan and I was like there's no cumin in
the recipe and was it because she felt
as though you you were leaving things
out well it's because she forgot
put cumin in the recipe she'd be like oh
there's actually cumin in this SOG feta
you also talked about because she's just
an intuitive cook she'll just sort of go
he just knows did you adopt that as well
or is that completely different from how
you honestly I there's this term in
Hindi it's called emboss which sort of
refers to that like you just kind of
know how much to add I don't have that I
fully understand but this was me sort of
documenting my mom's wishes since
tomorrow is Father's Day I want to give
your dad a moment because we helped you
send out book propose oh yeah you send
out like 5050 he email you the rejection
letters this was for my first book yeah
ultimate dining hall hacks yeah my dad
also very organized but he he got a
place in the book his his homemade
yogurt has a big spread in the book that
is like my bread and butter I grew up on
homemade yogurt always made by my dad I
love that you also had that there was a
story that you tell about this belief
that you had that you could put the book
out and you compared it to Legally
Blonde and Elwood's that was yeah that
was my first book ultimate dining hall
hacks I never published a book before I
didn't know the process of getting an
agent and going out to publishing houses
so I was just like yeah if I write the
proposal
the book will ha just like L going to
Harvard exactly exactly one instead of
writing we'll have you sign the dish oh
my gosh
and if you had had this meal with anyone
Chester president who would it be um it
would probably be my maternal
grandparents they passed away when I was
two years old so I never got to meet
them but my mom always talks about how
much they would have loved you know
sharing these these meals with us my
mom's mom hated cooking but loved eating
well we loved sharing with you Thank You
Priya Krishna for more on her and the
dish you can head to our website at CBS
this morning calm